today on the matt walsh show the army
has launched its own woke leftist ad
campaign
as both the intelligence community and
the military continue to
prioritize left-wing ideology over less
important concerns like you know
defending the country from its enemies
we'll discuss that also five headlines
including a change to the dictionary
that has now turned
myself and millions of others into
anti-vaxxers plus college students are
suspended for not wearing a mask
off-campus and outrage over a video of a
brutal full-contact drill
among little kids at a football practice
is the outrage overblown or do the
critics have a point
and our daily cancellation we'll discuss
the former msnbc host who has decided
that it should be legal to kill any
white man who uses a racial slur
and that perspective is more popular
than you'd like to think we'll talk
about that and much more today on the
matte wall show
so war rages again in the middle east
major fuel lines are disabled by shadowy
groups of international hackers
gas shortages ravage the east coast
inflation threatens to [ __ ] the
economy
anarchists terrorize american cities at
will police departments collapse
public trust in government plummets to
an all-time low the country faces an
unprecedented combination of crises all
at once but don't worry
everything is fine the good news is that
our government
is run by a dementia patient our
intelligence agencies are mostly focused
on promoting diversity
and the military is busy recruiting
feminists to defeat the threat posed by
intolerance
and hate speech on second thought
everything is not fine we would appear
to be to use the technical phrase
totally screwed and there's no sign of
common sense or sanity being restored in
the near future
which brings us to this on the heels of
an ad blitz by the ca
the cia touting its recruitment of
cisgender millennial women with anxiety
disorders
and gay men whose job is to keep the
campus library stocked with
stress-relieving board games
to help agents cope with their feelings
the us army has started its own
woke ad campaign a new page on the
army's website highlights the stories of
quote five young americans
who quote made the most important
decision of their lives for reasons as
diverse as they are
now the five americans all featured in a
series of short animated videos together
titled the calling
are of course exclusively immigrants and
women obviously the army doesn't want to
offend anyone by admitting that it has
white men in its ranks
most of the videos are basically
unobjectionable if somewhat odd
for example a a lieutenant describes how
he struggled in school
searching for his purpose in life before
deciding to pursue his lifelong goal of
becoming a pilot
he assures us quote it doesn't take a
genius to become an army pilot
now this is probably true it doesn't
take a genius to learn almost any skill
but
it still doesn't fill you with
confidence to hear the military making
that kind of pitch for itself hey guys
doesn't take a genius to do this
another video tells the tale of a first
lieutenant who eventually decided to
chase her dream of joining the army
after spending five years as a singer on
a cruise ship
a scene at the end of the little cartoon
shows her staring out from the deck of a
ship at sunset
singing about her soldiering dreams
let's watch that when i
was 17 i i
had such real big dreams i
said dad i wanna be a soldier
so i can be like you
and though the years have passed now
feeling just seems to last now
it's not too hard to grasp now
hey dad i gotta
feel like you
i'm just trying to imagine you know
old-school
old-school army veterans you know
vietnam war vet hasn't been paying much
attention recently
turns on the tv season ad for the army
that's that
it just thinks what in the hell
now i doubt that our adversaries will
tremble in their boots when they see
that our military recruitment ads
strongly resemble disney princess films
but that is all nothing compared to the
profile of corporal
emma malone lord now she tells us about
her childhood
growing up at a home with two lesbian
moms and her time spent marching for
lgbt rights
eventually in college she was inspired
by her sorority sisters to pursue quote
her own adventure
which is how she settled on a career in
the army where she says she can prove
her inner strength and
shatter stereotypes if you want to see
it which
i mean you probably don't but i'll show
it to you anyway here it is
although i had a fairly typical
childhood
took ballet played violin
i also marched for equality i like to
think i've been defending freedom from
an early age
when i was six years old one of my moms
had an accident that left her paralyzed
doctors said she might never walk again
but she tapped into my family's pride to
get back on her feet
eventually standing at the altar to
marry my other mom
with such powerful role models i
finished high school at the top of my
class
and then attended uc davis where i
joined a sorority full of other
strong women but as graduation
approached
i began feeling like i'd been handed so
much in life
a sorority girl stereotype sure
i'd spent my life around inspiring women
but what had i really achieved on my own
one of my sorority sisters was studying
abroad in italy another was climbing
mount everest
i needed my own adventures my own
challenge
and after meeting with an army recruiter
i found it
a way to prove my inner strength and
maybe shatter some stereotypes
along the way
i am let me say happy that emma
has found her inner strength but
there's a question here do we want to
promote the military as a forum of
self-discovery
for sorority girls whenever we next find
ourselves in an armed conflict with a
rival super
superpower and we certainly will
eventually probably sooner rather than
later
will the military be better equipped and
able to slaughter the enemy
now that it has made diversity its first
priority
now that it has sold itself as a place
to have an adventure and
prove your inner strength
it's quite telling that out of all five
of the soldiers featured in the video
series
only one says anything about wanting to
defend our nation from its enemies
national defense does not seem to be a
major priority of the department of
defense these days
perhaps that isn't entirely fair
actually let me back up
credit where it's due those entrusted to
defend and secure the homeland
are intent on defending and securing it
from at least one physical threat
that is the threat of white supremacy
the hill has
this report this week as well it says
quality by administration's top law
enforcement officials on wednesday
pledged to dedicate their resources to
combat domestic violent extremists amid
questions over
whether the agencies are equipped to
monitor such threats in the wake of the
january 6 capital riot
attorney general merrick garland and
homeland security secretary alejandro
mayorkas appeared before the senate
appropriations committee for a hearing
on domestic extremism as congress ramped
up its scrutiny this week
of the circumstances around the attack
of the capital both garland and mayorkas
testified that white supremacist groups
posed the most serious domestic national
security threat in the u.s reinforcing
what analysts have long concluded
about far-right organizations
both the attorney general and the
secretary of homeland security agreed
with senator patrick leahy's statement
that white supremacists represent quote
the most persistent lethal threat
let's watch that moment could you agree
with your
predecessors that white supremacist
extremists remain the most persistent
lethal threat in the homeland
i i do believe they they do at this time
mr chairman and attorney general garland
do you agree
i do and that's the most recent
assessment of the fbi
first of all when are the how old is
that guy
640 just retire
you people um
anyway going into more detail garland
went on to to claim that uh
the top domestic violent extremist
threat we face comes from racially or
ethnically motivated violent extremists
specifically those who advocate for the
superiority of the white race
in other words says garland the greatest
threat we face comes from
violent extremists but not the ones
who've been rampaging through our cities
inflicting billions of dollars of damage
blocking traffic harassing innocent
people
and attacking random bystanders those
extremists are often racially motivated
themselves
but they're not the ones we should be
worried about instead according to the
people at the highest levels of
government
the racially motivated extremists that
should attract our attention are the
ones who aren't doing anything
and are nowhere to be seen black
supremacists can whip up a mob of
thousands
in an instant in terrorized cities for
weeks on end
white supremacists can't do anything
close to that probably because they're
hampered by the fact
that they don't exist for the most part
which is a little bit of a logistical
challenge i have found
uh you know if you want to do something
but you don't exist it's kind of it it
presents problems
this is a threat that guys like garland
have fabricated now perhaps they
really are up at night frantically
tossing and turning screaming no
the white supremacists are coming but i
doubt it
the people who invent the boogeyman
don't actually believe in it themselves
it is more that they are politically
bound to this conclusion
but whatever the motivations we are left
with the reality that the people running
our government
and in charge of defending this country
against enemies foreign and domestic
are all either left-wing ideologues or
hollow shells and useful pawns for
left-wing ideologues
i mean all of them
at the highest levels they recognize no
duty more sacred and solemn than to
fulfill that role they are loyal only to
the ideology
they have infiltrated and effectively
incapacitated every institution
because they will not allow any
institution even the military to have
any priorities above and beyond
the propagation of left-wing doctrine
all things
and all people must be evangelists for
their religion
that is how everything and everyone's
ultimate purpose can be fulfilled in the
mind of our leftist overlords
and no doubt our enemies are watching
this happen
and laughing to themselves and licking
their chops and biding their time
all of this i guess is just a long way
of saying that you can start a free
trial of rosetta stone today
if you want to learn chinese which you
probably should
let's get now to our five headlines
uh we are man we're in the process of
moving right now
can i just whine and complain for one
second here and then for the rest of the
show
we've been living in a rental in uh
nashville but now we're moving
into our into our home um and it it is
it is really the worst i don't recommend
moving at all we've moved six or seven
times and it never gets easier
but at the same time especially when you
add like add more and more kids into the
equation
but at the same time it's also
potentially edifying because
it is it's an opportunity to confront
your own materialism
and so you know i've i've gone through
this
my wife and i we've gone through this
every time we move uh but and especially
in this most this is in this latest move
because you never realize how
materialistic you are until you move
and and you see all of your stuff in
boxes
and you think to yourself what what what
is that how do i have all this stuff
where did this come from how did i buy
all of this how am i not bankrupt
already from buying all this stuff
then you start going through the boxes
and you're like wait did i
did i buy this 12 foot statue of a frog
in a suit of armor
or whatever and then i think back i
think about
you know the the the oregon trail
okay early pioneers they would pack all
of their it's like
a family of 17 and they would pack all
of their belongings
everything they owned in a wagon and set
off
into the wilderness and these days a
family of
three you know you need 14 trucks
to move across uh then across the city
it really is sad of course on the oregon
trail the other thing is uh
family of 16 like half of them would die
on the way so i guess they needed less
stuff once they got there but still the
point is a lot of materialism and i'm uh
very much part of the problem all right
let's start here we should probably
start with
i think the big news the big news is
that now i am officially an anti-vaxxer
this is my coming out
moment um i'm coming out as an
anti-vaxxer
i can finally reveal my true identity
i begin my new life today as an
anti-vaxxer pretty exciting
you probably do as well i never really
expected to be an anti-vaxxer
um but according to the newly revamped
dictionary i am
so zoobee who's a rapper and a
conservative and has a pretty big social
media following he tweeted this
the merriam-webster dictionary has
changed their definition of anti-vaxxer
to include
quote people who oppose laws that
mandate vaccination
welcome to 1984 this is the ministry of
truth so if you oppose laws
that mandate vaccination that now makes
you an anti-vaxxer
according to the change in the
dictionary
which of course is how that label that
term has
is has been used now for several months
because you know when you think
anti-vaxxer someone who's
anti-vaccine you think oh that's someone
who's anti-vaccine they're against
vaccines
and there are some people in that camp
some who are against all vaccines
but i think it's a probably a pretty
small category and then there are more
people who are
kind of more skeptical about vaccines
they're not against all of them in
principle but they
you know they're also not going to just
take every single vaccine that they're
told to take or they're not going to
give every vaccine
every vaccine to their kid that they're
told you know they want to know a little
bit more about it
which is a reasonable perspective
and then there are the people who even
aside from the vaccines themselves
don't think that the government should
be forcing its citizens to inject
substances into their body no matter
what the substance is
and uh i am very much in that category
as far as the vaccines themselves as
i've said a million times
my position on whether or not you should
get the vaccine is
i frankly don't care that's totally your
decision
completely up to you i don't have an
opinion about what things you
you should inject into your body that's
you got to make your own decision
and uh and that's fine and if if there's
a whether we're talking about
covid or any other communicable disease
and there's a vaccine available for it
if i trust the vaccine and i'm worried
about it i can get a vaccine and then
you know it doesn't affect me what your
choice is
but as far as whether or not people
should be forced to do it obviously not
yep anti-vaxxer so that's we we have now
the the anti-vaxxing
ranks have probably grown a hundred fold
just with this change in definition all
right
uh number two cbs reports this fulton
county district attorney fannie willis
says she will seek the death penalty for
the atlanta spa shooting suspects
despite campaigning on her opposition to
it
this is pretty revealing this is someone
who campaigned
member of the far left supposedly
anti-death penalty campaigned as
as as anti-death penalty uh and
obviously when you're
when you're campaigning as a district
attorney the death penalty is not some
academic issue it's it's really
important uh very relevant to the
position that you're going to be
that you're campaigning to to win she
said she's the anti-death penalty that
was what
a year ago that she was campaigning as
an anti-death penalty now she's changed
her mind
let's listen to her explain her change
of heart i
along with my staff have made a
determination
that this office will seek the death
penalty
last year i told the voters of fulton
county
that i could not imagine a circumstance
where i would seek it
and at that time i did not unfortunately
a case has arisen in the first few
months of my term
that i believe warrants the ultimate
penalty
and we shall seek it by the way
to begin with me let me say uh i agree
that it warrants the ultimate penalty
you go and randomly sw slaughter
innocent people
you should get a death penalty i'm fully
on board with that
but i would have said that before the
spa
shootings in atlanta
um yet she's completely changed her
position and that only shows
that it and i think this is very often
the case
on the left that the opposition to the
death penalty is not
it's not based in any coherent
solid principle and we know that it
can't
be because these are our people who
believe in executing
babies in the womb so when they say
they're against
executions they're against the death
penalty we already know
that there's a huge huge exception there
asterisks and it's
a huge exception uh except for
all the babies in the womb so we know
that already it's not based on any real
principle
what is a basement well political
political expedience for one
and um and emotion really
it's an emotional thing most of the time
someone like fanny willis
she feels you know
she can she she certainly can't
empathize with
she has no real empathy for babies in
the womb
because he can't see the babies in the
womb
they can't advocate for themselves
you know we we can have interviews and
things with uh with criminals on death
row
and you see them sitting there pathetic
and
weak and just and and you know they're
behind bars and obviously now that
they're behind bars they're not really a
threat to anyone
so they've been neutered they're
pathetic they're weak they're just
sitting there
someone like fanny willis she can
connect with them
and feel some empathy sometimes
you can't do that with babies in the
womb there's no interviews with them
there's no documentaries where we where
we can
interview and get their perspective on
it
they are silent they are hidden
and so there's no emotional connection
at least for people on the left and so
we say we'll go ahead and slaughter them
no big deal
not the case for uh for the people on
death row and so it's all emotional
but in this case her emotions are are
different
because what she considers you know
even though it's never even been
established
that the the killer in the atlanta spa
shootings was motivated by race
in fact all indications are that he
wasn't motivated by race he's not a
this was not a racist killing and it
doesn't matter anyway
you slaughter all those people it's what
is what does your motive even really
matter
it's not like there's any motive you
could have for doing that that would
make it worse it's already the worst
thing that you can do it's as bad as it
gets
so your motive for my mind is a moot
point
but for fannie willis um
she number one considers him a racist
and has decided this is race motivated
even if it wasn't
and being a racist is the ultimate sin
that's even actually worse than
murder so we're going to execute him
you know she says like this this is a
crime that warrants the ultimate penalty
okay again agreed
but i don't know i i think it probably
wouldn't take me very long on google
to find a lot of horrific crimes that
have been committed in atlanta
did none of them warrant the ultimate
penalty
i am quite certain that i could right
now on google
find examples over the last year of
children
being murdered in atlanta
that didn't warrant the ultimate penalty
why not
just no principle here whatsoever all
right let's move uh number three here
this is from fox a video of a youth
football drill went viral tuesday and
sparked outrage on social media
with many wondering whether children
should be doing something like this the
eight second clip shows a young ball
carrier going head-to-head with a
would-be tackler
uh the ball carrier lowers his helmet
and runs over the defender and appeared
the two connected with each other's
helmets the defender hit the ground was
a little shaken up video shows it's
unclear when the video was taken or what
you
youth football program was hosting the
drills the tennessee titans logo was on
the field
and the players helmets the titans usa
football and pop warner didn't
immediately respond to fox news requests
for comment on the video uh this went
pretty viral yesterday
a bunch of sports media people and
former nfl guys
chimed in on it and they were all very
much on the side of uh
they were they were all outraged at the
coach and they said that this drill is
not appropriate for kids
we have the clip let's um let's play
this here let's play the clip
you're the kids lined up
i wanted to play that because i wanted
you to hear number one you hear the
reaction from the coaches they're
laughing
and if you're if you're watching this on
youtube or on dailywire.com you can see
the kids and how and how they match up
so it's kind of like a pursuit tackling
drill and the one
the ball carrier has i mean several
inches
on the uh the tackle or the would be
tackler
and i would guess like you know seven or
eight pounds as well which is a lot at
that age
so they are not evenly matched up
these are young kids i mean how old are
these kids probably i don't know eight
eight years old maybe
um these are young kids not evenly
matched up
the the you know the tackler doesn't
have proper form at all
which is which is which is expected at
that age but he runs in
now you got to get down you got to get
low to make that tackle but he runs in
he's standing straight up
and then the the ball carrier hits them
helm it's clearly helmet to helmet
contact which is which is
you know against the rules in in
football
and then and then the kid falls back and
he smacks the back of his head
against the ground that's got concussion
written all over i would be shocked if
that little kid that eight-year-old kid
does not have a concussion from that i
mean almost certainly he's got a
concussion
because he gets he gets smacked in the
front of his head and then he hits the
ground
hard on the back of his head the first
part of his body to hit the ground is
his head
absorbing all of that impact
you watch that you think and we don't
know the context here and as the fox
news article says we don't know
where this was or anything seems like it
was probably probably local here in
nashville because of the tennessee
titans
logo but we don't really know um
but i think there are some pretty safe
assumptions we can make
one is that the coaches or whoever is
filming this
why are they filming it it seems likely
that they filmed it because they knew
that these kids were not evenly matched
and the one kid was about to get blown
up and they knew it
and so they filmed it so they could get
so that so they could get that
so they thought it'd be funny so they've
got a kid
it would seem sustaining potential head
trauma for their amusement and they
think it's funny that is uh
look i'm all about i i'm fine with kids
playing football
this is this is an argument i have with
my wife sometimes i
you know i think it's fine to have kids
play football she's she's
does doesn't really like the idea for
for this exact reason
um so we go back and forth about that
sometimes but personally i'm fine with
kids playing football
and i'm all about like you got to
toughen kids up you got especially boys
you got to toughen them up a little
tough love sometimes
uh you know i'm not i'm not big into
babying kids as you can imagine
but this is just not acceptable at all
that is that's actually horrific that
that that
you know you could make an argument
that's criminal
if i'm right that they knew these kids
were
unevenly matched and that and that kid
was about to be smacked to the ground
like that and they filmed it because of
it
for their amusement then i think this
goes beyond bad coaching and we could
look at criminal
charges this is a serious deal
head head injuries at any age but
especially for kids as they're growing
that's not some small thing
the effects of that in the long term can
be devastating
and really look there's there's no
reason for kids at that age
to be running a drill like that
you know you don't run a drill like that
pursuit tackling full on you know head
of st
you got to make a tackle on a guy when
he's coming he's got a full head of
steam he's coming at you
you don't run a drill like that until
everybody on the team has
absolutely mastered the form of tackling
has mastered the the art of tackling
and probably most eight-year-olds
haven't aren't gonna master it
so there's no reason to be running that
drill or drill anything like it at that
age
at that age it should be all about
learning the form and yeah you can there
are drills you can do
to learn uh pursuit tackling to learn
form tackling without actually having
full-on collisions like that
and that's what they should be doing
um without the full contact learning
learning just running through the drills
learning the form learning the form
drilling that into their head
and then later on at the older ages
that's when you introduce
the full contact head of steam
collisions like that
so i think that's pretty that's that's
just pretty horrific
um and it's uh
you know this is one of the reasons why
when you watch the nfl
a lot of the tackling the nfl even now
is is horrible they got a horrible form
because you go down to the earliest ages
and they have these idiot coaches who
don't know what they're doing and aren't
teaching proper form
so even in the nfl you see these
defenders the way that they the way they
try to make
tackles is just by launching like a
torpedo they just launch their whole
body at someone they don't wrap up they
don't do anything like that
this is where it starts young ages all
right um let's go here another article
for fox news it says the parents of
three university of massachusetts
amherst students who were suspended for
allegedly violating
the school's coven 19 health policy told
fox and friends
the draconian punishment was completely
overkill the decision was reportedly was
made after school administrators
got hold of a photo of the trio mask
list
at a party off campus the students all
women were first
removed from campus and then were cut
off from their remote lessons
um and then they they talked about the
situation on fox and friends but they
were
so they were off campus not even on
campus
and now they're suspended for not
wearing a mask
how did the school find out about this
well apparently they posted the pictures
to i guess it was
instagram or some social media thing and
then someone else at the school another
student apparently uh
took the screenshot and sent that over
to the school and said look what they're
doing
teacher teacher
that's one element one part of the story
over the last year
that i maybe the thing that i find most
disturbing is all of the snitching that
has gone on
among citizens
i wish that this was just a us verse
them
type of thing and you have the the
government
tyrants oppressing you know
the public and we're all we're all in it
together that's what we've been told
we're all in this together
i wish i could say that but it hasn't
been quite that simple
because a lot of just average citizens
have shown themselves
perfectly willing and even eager
to turn on uh on their neighbors or
their classmates
snitch on them get them in trouble
because that's power too you know that's
we talked yesterday about
these government bureaucrats and
everything and and how they've
we've given them all this power they're
reluctant of course to give it back
but a lot of average citizens also find
power
when they can you know get someone in
trouble they can manipulate
impose their will through the means of
government force
and they don't want to they don't want
to give up on that either
all right let's uh okay finally we have
this from cbs it says officials are
warning people not to pour
gasoline into plastic bags amid panic
over a shortage of gas in southeastern
states
um the u.s consumer product safety
commission
posted a flurry of tweets advising
people not to carry gasoline in plastic
bags or any other container not approved
to carry fuel
the agency tweeted on wednesday do not
fill plastic bags with gasoline
we know this sounds simple but when
people get desperate they stop thinking
clearly
then it also says there's a there's
actually a bunch of tweets about basic
safety with when when you know
using gasoline another one was um don't
pour
gasoline over an open flame
uh you know this might be one of those
darwin darwin award type things where if
someone needs that
there are some lessons you just need
people to learn the hard way i don't
know maybe that's one of them
is that actually a pr is that a thing is
that a problem people pouring gasoline
into plastic bags
or is this the government inventing a
problem
just to give them an excuse to lecture
us i don't know
all right let's move on now to reading
the youtube comments this is from jesse
b
says matt you're 100 dad listening to
expound on the joys of parenthood and
the visuals you gave for yourself and
wife as a young couple growing together
through the years and stages of
parenthood
could be a poem that was sweet
well it's not very often that people
have a reason to call me sweet but i
will
normally that will get you banned but
i'm feeling nice today so i'll let it go
adam says my wife is very a very
successful surgeon but she always says
being a mother is her greatest
accomplishment
well you know adam that's a nice
sentiment and it sounds like your wife
is a great woman and a great mother
i will say though not to be pedantic but
being a mother
is not her greatest accomplishment
because it's not an accomplishment at
all
simply being a mother is not an
accomplishment literally any physically
healthy woman can be a mom right
there's no achievement there the
achievement
is to be a good mom to be a good parent
which i'm sure she is i'm not saying she
isn't but
i do think it's important for us to
remember that if we want to call
parenting and accomplishment um
we have to earn that and sometimes maybe
as parents we could lose sight of it so
it is important to remind ourselves
i'm sure your wife has earned it or will
i'm offering this as kind of a general
thought
it's kind of like you hear parents all
the time say uh having a kid was the
greatest thing i ever did the best the
best thing i ever did
and it can be and i hope it was
but that's also up to you it's not it's
it's you have the kid but then there's
the whole
that's the easy part especially easy if
you're the man the having the kid part
because we don't
we don't really have much of a role at
all although we still have
more of a role in that than i wish
because i wish we were back in the 50s
when the man
would be at the hospital they have the
smoking room and we're gonna we're just
out there smoking waiting for the deed
to be done
everything's cleaned up and then we're
called back into the room i would prefer
that
but either way even for the women the
hat the actual having of the child
is the easy part compared to the
challenge of now being a parent on a
day-to-day basis
um and that's where you know
that's where the accomplishment comes
from now being
a good parent
for for years right every single day
waking up every single day
and being a good parent not perfect but
good
that is extremely difficult and if you
can pull that off
in a sustained fashion then i would say
that is
a great achievement and would probably
be anyone's greatest achievement in life
um trust me says here's my thought when
i hear fauci speak
good thing the emperor wears no clothes
it allows us to feel to see how full of
bat guano he is
you know i gotta say i prefer not to
think of fouchy naked
my god i just thought about it i'll
never recover from this this is your
fault
you put that thought in my head um mr
quang says matt i tried finding a wife
when i was young but didn't find my wife
until i was in my late 30s i agree with
you completely about getting married and
having kids when you're young
because it's hard for me to keep up with
my two young boys but god didn't
have me marry and have kids until i was
older so i'm going to encourage my kids
to get married when they're in their 20s
right that's why we're talking about the
advantages of marrying young and how it
should be encouraged
in society it's better generally
speaking that people are getting married
younger than than
the situation we have now uh but that's
also why i said
it's that's not gonna be it's not how
it's gonna work for everybody
so your own individual situation might
be different but when we talk about what
our general goal should be and attitude
should be i think that should be it
um christian says please react to the
masterpiece back in blood by pou
sheiste i think it has a lot to say
about the essence of human existence and
is one of the finest pieces of musical
art the current generation has produced
what pooh sheisty is is this a rapper i
assume
poo sheisty what
i assume as i don't know exactly what
the process is as a rapper for picking a
a name
what your rap name is going to be but i
assume you can really pick anything you
want
and you go with poo poo is in winnie the
pooh
i assume to have a name like that and
pull that i don't know anything about
about mr pooch isd
but i will assume to have you got to be
a real tough guy
you know to pull off a name like that
and to not be ruthlessly mocked for it
every single day
i gotta assume this is a a tough guy but
i'll look into that song and maybe we'll
review it if i
and i i believe you 100 that it sounds
like it probably is a fine piece of art
and i'll look into that and finally
carrie says i love how as soon as matt
demanded everyone hit the like button
the likes jumped by about 500 likes did
they really
maybe that's it so you have all these
other youtubers who are
groveling for likes hey smash that like
button
yuck come on um but maybe maybe i've
stumbled on what it really is you have
to demand
put down your foot and demand it hit
that like button
hit it right now we'll see if it worked
again
i prefer i prefer that method you know
that i'm always right
about even when i contradict myself i'm
right on both ends somehow
so when i say we're in the middle of an
authoritarian power grab by the out of
touch weirdos at the top
you should probably believe me uh and if
you don't just think about that for a
moment lockdowns
cancel culture the ideological
indoctrination of children and i'm
always talking about it's all right
there
that's why you should pick up a copy of
ben shapiro's new book the authoritarian
moment
to learn how we got here and how to
fight back so if you want to preserve
your individual rights and protect the
ones you love from mob rule
the authoritarian moment is now
available for pre-order at amazon barnes
noble or any other major bookseller go
there now make sure to pre-order
now let's get to our daily cancellation
our daily cancellation today surely one
of the most deserving cancellations i
have yet dished out starts with a story
out of dunkin donuts in tampa florida
last week according to police a dunkin
donuts employee named corey pujols
punched a 77 year old customer in the
head knocked him to the ground and
fractured his skull the victim died in
the hospital two days later
pujols was has been has been charged
with aggravated
manslaughter because of it now the
assailant says that he assaulted the
elderly man because the man had
repeatedly used a racial slur
apparently the man was upset about what
he perceived to be poor servants and
duggan donuts that day
they they argued things escalated and
that's when the victim allegedly used
the slur
we're not told what the slur was
nor is there any proof that it actually
was used
it doesn't really matter what was said
obviously as no word
could possibly justify murder but it is
worth noting all the same that the
assailant
claims a slur was used by no means does
that guarantee that it actually was
used because he used the racial slur as
an excuse often offered in these
situations and very often it ends up
being a lie
either way in this case the assailant
killed someone
and uh that's all that matters here at
least as far as i could tell
enter now former msnbc host tori neblet
the daily wire reports quote neblet
publicly celebrated the death of a 77
year old white man who
was reportedly punched by a black
employee after using a racial slur to
duck a donuts
tory who goes by his first name hit up
social media to celebrate
he wrote quote a 77 year old white
customer doug donots was upset about
something and he called a black 27 year
old employee the n-word
the brother told him to say it again the
old man did the brother knocked him out
the old man fell lost consciousness and
died he effed around and found out
tori was not yet done celebrating and
justifying the physical assault later
asserting that saying the n-word is a
quote violent act
and he classified pujols as deadly
assault as self-defense
torrey said how else will white people
learn
if there was an actual justice in this
country as opposed to white justice
then if you went to someone's minimum
wage job and called them the n-word
twice
whatever happened after that would be
legally acceptable
tori went on for a while longer you know
he uh he was arguing his case that a
black man has a right to murder you in
self-defense if you say a word that
makes him sad
he even posted a poll asking his
followers if if they believe that a
black man who kills a white man for
saying a word should be acquitted
in the poll 70 of his followers said yes
he should be acquitted now i wish that i
could just chalk this up to tori being a
horrible person an idiot
a psychopath and he is indeed all of
those things but he's not alone this is
a prevailing belief
there is a prevailing belief out there
that white people who utter certain
syllables
ought to lose their right to live and
we've known about this belief for a
while just think back to last summer
when a macy's employee was brutally
assaulted
by a black man on film and it was
roundly celebrated because the black man
claimed
that the employee used the n-word and
that turned out to be a lie because
again these claims are very often lies
but the fact is that lots of people were
willing to give him a pass for felony
assault on the basis that he heard a
word
that made his tummy hurt indeed even
after the story was revealed as a lie
lots of people still wanted to give him
a pass because the victim was white and
therefore probably deserved it anyway
for one reason or another
i mean he might not have said the n word
but he might have thought it
or at least at some point in the past he
probably has said it or thought it or
maybe probably heard it like in a song
or something and therefore thought it
it seems like a rather fruitless
exercise to actually engage
intellectually with the argument that
black people have the right to kill
other humans who use bad words
but it seems we have to engage with it
because this is an idea that is far more
popular than you'd like to believe
and on that end i have a couple brief
thoughts
first of all we have here another
example
a big example of the bigotry of low
expectations
now tori is black himself so it's a sort
of strange
self-bigotry self-loathing thing in his
case
certainly among the white people who
endorse tory's point of view and again
there are more in that camp than you'd
like to believe
uh what they're saying is that the black
man who kills the white man over a word
cannot be expected to control himself it
would be unreasonable as the logic goes
to demand that he refrain from beating
an elderly man to death
he's upset and we must allow him to
convey his emotions in whatever way
feels right to him
we can't expect anything more a similar
attitude is taken towards rioters and
looters who
whose uh wanton destruction must be
understood and sympathize with because
as we are reminded
they're sad and they're angry and and
what else can we expect them to do
we have heard that exact argument many
times
well they're they're angry what else
would you expect of them
this along with being totally insane is
also horrifically demeaning and
degrading
as much as i decry the double standard
that gives one person license to act out
violently but not another and grants the
license based on race
at the same time i'm not sure i'd want
anyone to ever argue in my favor and on
my behalf
by saying that i should be allowed to
kill people or burn down buildings when
i'm angry
and that it'd be oppressive to hold me
to a standard of basic human decency
that's the kind of advocacy that i don't
want for me
now second point it must be reiterated
that the n-word assuming that's what the
victim in this case said if he said
anything at all
the n-word is not a mystical incantation
it doesn't have magical powers despite
what tori argues it's not some sort of
witches spell that might physically harm
you and
and therefore you need to physically
defend yourself against it
it's a word it's just a word
it's a bad word it's a slur it is right
in line with many other slurs and
profanities there are a lot of them out
there
all of these words are words
they are comprised of syllables they are
sounds that a person makes with their
mouth the special power and near
mystical quality that we've attributed
to this one word and this one word alone
is absurd and indefensible on every
level
the rules which decree that you may say
the word in any context if you have a
certain skin tone but if you have
another skin tone
you can't say it in any context not even
when quoting someone or reading from a
book
and if you do say it you could be killed
all of this is
abject lunacy
the thing is everybody knows that it's
lunacy
everyone knows it
but it's lunacy that we're expected to
simply accept without question
and you know there's a lot of that sort
of thing in our culture today
and that is why tori today is most
definitely
absolutely and we'll leave it there for
today
thanks for listening thanks for watching
have a great day godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 libs make a martyr out of liz
cheney
rand paul rips dr fauci and fareed
zakaria pushes a failed foreign policy
by repeating the same old slogans
check it out on the michael knowles show